the Saints kicker might have the most
interesting Journey to the NFL his name
is Lou Hedley he's from Australia and he
just signed with New Orleans as a 30
year old so what took him so long to get
to the NFL and how did he even get
interested in football Headley dropped
out of high school because he wanted to
start earning some money so he became a
scaffolder he then decided he wanted to
open up his own tattoo shop but not in
Australia Lou went to Indonesia he was
tatting up people for some time before
football started way heavier and heavier
on his mind you see Lou had played
Australian Rules Football growing up but
he gave up because he never thought he
could go pro in Australia so he decided
to take a whole other path he enrolled
in Pro kick a program that Scouts
Australian kickers for the NFL where he
got tons of attention from college
Scouts so he sells his stake in the
tattoo shop so he could have the funds
to move to the U.S he enrolls in the
City College of San Francisco absolutely
crushes it and power five schools come
knocking on his door he commits to Miami
as a 25 year old where he averaged 45.2
yards per Punt and now he's in the NFL
taking third year Pro Blake Gilligan's
starting spot what a journey